Well, if you've got a Bible, do please take it in turn with me to Deuteronomy chapter 6.
Deuteronomy chapter 6. For those of you who have the luxury of having a worship guide,
it is also there as well. Deuteronomy chapter 6. If you want to get a good debate going,
pick a category and say who is the greatest. I don't know if it's maybe basketball,
you can start to debate who's the greatest. Is it Michael Jordan or is it LeBron James?
Which is better, cats or dogs? And how somebody could ever say cats? I have no idea, but that's just
me. But when it comes to the greatest commandment in Scripture, we might wonder, well, can we actually
pick which is the greatest commandment? But somebody actually asked Jesus this one time.
They said, what is the greatest commandment? And he did not hesitate to answer. And when
he answered, he quoted the very passage that we are about to read together. And so Jesus says,
this is the greatest commandment. So let's listen carefully for this is the word of the Lord.
We're going to read Deuteronomy chapter 6 verses 4 to 9. It says,
Let's pray.
Lord, as we've just sung, we pray now that you would tune our hearts to sing your grace.
Lord, so often our hearts are not in tune with you. So Lord, we pray that by your spirit,
you would cause us to see more of the beauty and glory that you have revealed in your word
about who you are and what you have done for us. Lord, I pray that you would cause us to
believe and to rejoice in who you are. And that we would be ready to follow you now and forevermore.
I pray all this in Jesus' name. Amen. Amen. Well, attentiveness is very important.
I don't think it's going to be a surprising statement to anybody to say it feels like our
attention spans are growing shorter than they used to be. And actually studies have been done
that show that that is actually the case. It's not just something that we feel is the case,
but there's some data out there that seems to suggest that our attention span has shifted
for being able to focus on one thing from about two and a half minutes traditionally
to now it being about 45 seconds. And our lack of attentiveness can be detrimental in lots of
different ways. I mean, particularly you think of like relationships and like being on the phone
as opposed to being with a person right in front of you or whatever. But a lack of
attentiveness can be dangerous as well. They say about 25% or so of all automobile accidents
involve a phone. And so somebody's on their phone instead of paying attention to the road.
So attentiveness is extremely important and it can have an impact in all kinds of areas of our
lives. Well, the text we are looking at this morning calls us to attention. It calls us to
be attentive to the relationship that is most important. It calls our attention to the one who
is most important. It calls us to be attentive to God Himself. So this passage is most commonly
referred to as the Shema. So the Shema is a confession of faith that practicing Jews for
thousands of years have incorporated into their morning and evening prayers. And that
continues on to this day when they recite the words that we just read. And the word Shema
is the Hebrew word for the first word in the passage here. It says here, oh Israel. It's saying
Shema, oh Israel. And that word conveys more than just like perceiving sounds when it comes to
hearing. The word Shema conveys the idea of actively listening with a view to obeying.
In other words, our lives should be shaped by the Shema. So that's why I'm kind of taking as the
title for the message this morning, shaped by the Shema. In the book of Deuteronomy, Moses
is standing before a new generation of the people of Israel just before they go into the
Promised Land. In the previous generation, although they heard the word of the Lord,
they failed to pay attention truly and to walk in obedience. But now Moses is proclaiming God's
word to this new generation, if you will, and calling them to truly listen to God, to pay attention
to him. So I want to ask us this question this morning in a world that is full of distractions.
What has your attention? What fills your thoughts? What shapes your decisions? What kind of impact
is it having? What are you attentive to? Because we're all attentive to something or many things.
So I want us to see the importance of being attentive to God and being shaped by his word,
being shaped by the Shema. Alright, so just three simple things we'll look at. The first thing
is, who is it that we are called to be attentive to here? It makes it clear here, oh Israel, verse 4,
the Lord our God, the Lord is one. So twice it's repeated, the Lord, the Lord. So our attention
is being called to God himself. So Moses is saying to the people of Israel, behold your God
above all else, be attentive to him. See who he truly is and respond in kind. Alright, so what is
he telling us about the Lord here? Well this word that is repeated twice, the Lord, the Lord, is the
word Yahweh. So this is the unique name of God that he revealed himself by to the covenant people
of Israel. So he's saying, this is who I am, I am the Lord. But there's a particular point of
emphasis that he is making when he says this twice. The Lord our God, the Lord is what? The Lord is one.
So speaking of God's oneness. So what's it talking about here? It's talking about, first of all,
God's uniqueness when it says that he is one. So there is no one like him. So remember the
people of Israel are surrounded by all kinds of idolatrous nations all around them. They're
surrounded by nations that are polytheistic. In other words, they worship many different gods.
But that was not to be the case for God's people. Because Yahweh alone is God. He is the one,
true and living God. Therefore, they were to worship him alone as God because he is uniquely
God. He is one. There's one God. So what does that mean for the Trinity? Do we make a mistake
when we name this church Trinity Fellowship? Absolutely not. Affirming the oneness of God isn't
denying the fact that he is also the triune God. So the God who revealed that he is one has also
revealed that he, the one God is Father, Son and Holy Spirit. The Father, the Son and the Holy
Spirit have eternally existed together as this one God. He alone is God, the God who is Father,
Son and Spirit. So speaks of his uniqueness. But it also speaks of our unique relationship with
God. So he's talking about his unique relationship with his people. Notice it just doesn't just
say the Lord is one. It says the Lord, our God, the Lord is one. So there's a tension drawn to
their relationship with God. This relationship, we might say, is a relationship of covenant love.
All right. So God has brought the people of Israel into this covenant relationship with himself.
He has set his love upon them. He has made them his own people. He has saved them and brought them to
himself. And covenant love is exclusive love. There's, there's, it's conveying an exclusive
relationship here, a unique relationship that God has with his people. So everybody,
so God is the creator of everyone. But there is a unique relationship that those who have been
saved and made his own have with God. It's this relationship of covenant love. And so if you're
in this relationship of covenant love with God, there's an exclusivity to this relationship.
You are to worship him alone. He alone is your God. So weddings are wonderful,
lots of wonderful things on the day. But the most important part of a wedding ceremony is what?
It's the, it's the vows that are made. It's the promises that are made in the, in the covenant
of marriage. And one of the, one of the things that comes through in the, in the traditional
vows is, is three important words. And it is forsaking all others. Right. So, so there's,
you're entering into this relationship of covenant love. And it is just this one man and one
woman for life forsaking all others. So they're not committing to be mostly married to each other.
It's a statement of exclusivity saying, I want to be married to you and to you alone.
So the people of Israel weren't to just mostly worship God more than any other God. Any more
than like a husband or a wife is married to their spouse a bit more than any other kind of partner
they might have elsewhere. No, it's exclusive. And so is the case with the church, the bride of Christ.
You see this one who is the Lord who is one, the one who is worthy of all worship has set
his love upon us. And the son was willing to lay down his life for us on the cross to make us
his own. So he's, he's loved us in that way to bring us into this covenant relationship
with himself. And this relationship that we have with him is to be marked by worshiping him
and him alone. We might think, well, no problem, you know, idolatry is not really a problem in
this part of the world. I mean, maybe a place where Hinduism is prevalent, you know, where we
might bow down to other idols or worship other gods in that way. But I'd say not so fast.
Scripture makes it clear that idolatry or worshiping other gods than the one true God.
Scripture makes clear that it extends beyond worshiping physical objects that are like
representations of false gods. So Ezekiel chapter 14 and verse three, for example,
speaks about how we can create idols in our hearts. We can bow down before things as it were
internally, even if we're not worshiping some external idol. You go to the New Testament,
Colossians chapter three and verse five, it speaks about covetousness as idolatry. In other words,
craving and desiring things more than God or desiring things that God has not seen fit to
give you by his grace. Desiring those things, that is idolatry. It's these disordered desires
going after things that are not God being distracted by those things. So everybody worships.
Right. The question is not do I worship or not. The question is, what do I worship or
who do I worship? And then another way of saying that is, what am I giving my attention to?
What fills my thoughts? What are my desires chasing after? What is shaping my decision
making? And if it's anything else other than the God who is one, then we are chasing after
something else. We're worshiping a false idol. And if it's not God, it will never satisfy.
We worship him alone because he alone is worthy and he alone satisfies. So whether you have
never seen his glory or you have seen his glory and yet you have a wondering eye to other
desires, the call of this passage is the same for all of us. Behold him. See his glory. See
his beauty. See him as the one who alone is worthy of worship.
Pay attention. Shema. All right. So this is who we're paying attention to. The Lord who is one.
The Lord who has brought us in this relationship with himself. This one we worship. But
secondly, okay, then how are we to respond to him? Right? So we know we're paying attention to him,
but it calls us to more like as we're attentive to the Lord, what does it say?
Here are Israel, the Lord our God, the Lord is one. Verse five, you shall love the Lord,
your God with all your heart and with all your soul and with all your might. So we
respond to this revelation of the God who loves us by loving him in return.
Right? So he loves us and we love him. So I know a man from Alabama once said,
I may not be a very smart man, but I know what love is. But we still need to be,
that was forced up if you don't know the reference, sorry. We still need to be reminded
of what love truly is. So what is the definition of love? Well, love in scripture speaks about our
feelings, yes, like our affections, but it also speaks about taking care of others.
It speaks about like parental love, for example. So what a great day for us to think about love
than Mother's Day. So like we can think of mothers as being those who have affection for
their children, but also take care of their children in lots of wonderful and sacrificial
ways. But all human love is pointing to the greatest love, which is the love of God.
We can think of the love of God both in his affections, but also it's seen in what he
does as well. So scripture speaks of God as being the source of love. It even says God is love.
Right? So it's part of his character. It is flowing from the very essence of his
being. So right? So he is the source of love. But also God is a God who loves. He sets his love
on people. So I keep talking about God setting his love on Israel or setting his love on us.
You see that actually in Deuteronomy chapter seven. So I'd encourage you to take time to read that
passage speaking about God setting that love of his on people. But the way we see that he has set
his love on them here, his affections on them is in his actions toward them. Like he saves them.
He brings them to himself. So love is affection and it is action in God.
But God has also shown us this same kind of love in Jesus. Like there's nothing,
you know, when God speaks about his love for Israel in Deuteronomy 70, there wasn't anything
in them. It's clear that that drew his love. Rather he just chose to set his love upon them.
So in Jesus we see this like we're sinful people. Like there's nothing attractive in us as it were
that has drawn God's love to us. But rather God has chosen to set his love upon us because he is
loving. So in Jesus we see that God loves us and he loves us to the degree that he was even
willing to lay down his life for us to rescue us from sin and death and bring us into this eternal
relationship with him. So it's love in action, the greatest love ever known.
And then in love he brings us by his spirit into that relationship. The spirit of God opens our
eyes to see the love of God revealed in Jesus. And then Romans 5 says that God's love is
then poured out into our hearts through the Spirit that he has given to us. So what does it mean
then for us to love God, right? The commands to us, like love God. Well it involves our
affections and our actions. It's setting our affections upon God, right? So the spirit of
God shows us that he is glorious. And so then we set our affections upon him. When we see the
beauty of the Lord our attention is drawn to him and we find satisfaction in him and we grow to
desire him above all else. He doesn't need that from us. But he gives us this love. We might
experience this loving relationship with himself but also he doesn't need us. So if we say,
well okay well love is the affections thing but if love is taking care of somebody else
what does God then need from us? God doesn't need us to take care of him in any kind of way and yet
our love for God involves action as well. So we set our affections upon him and we
give our lives to him completely. So our love for God is demonstrated by
surrendering our lives to him. It is seen in our obedience to him. So 1 John chapter 5
in verse 3 says, for this is the love of God that we keep his commandments.
And the thing is, here's how that is, the love of God being demonstrated. Because we, although we,
yes we ought to keep God's commandments. Like we have to. It's required of us. But because we
love God we want to do that which is pleasing to him. Like we want to keep his commandments.
And that is where love for God is seen. It's made visible in how we live. So that's
the kind of definition of love then. Or feelings and our actions. But it also speaks not only just
to the definition of love but also the degree of love. It says to love God with what? With all your
heart. With all your soul. With all your strength. Before Julia and I got married,
we went on a walk out in a country park in England. And it was a day just like yesterday.
How many of you went out for a nice stroll yesterday? It was pouring down with rain. But hey,
we were young and in love. And it didn't matter to us at all. You know trekking through the mud
together. And so we're walking through the rain. There's nobody else in this park. And we find this
park bench. And we sit down on this park bench together with our one umbrella. We sat under this
one umbrella together just gazing into each other's eyes or whatever it was we were doing.
And we still do that. And so under this umbrella and finally somebody walks up. It's a dog
walker. Like the dog had to be walked. Right. Had to get outside. It's a dog walker walks up,
you know, in his raincoat. And he looks over at us like we have lost our minds. And then he
then walked past us and turned back around. He said, it must be love. He just kept walking.
But he was right. It was love. Love causes you to do things that might look strange to other
people around you. You have that kind of attentiveness, the kind of all inness,
so to speak. So here it's saying love God in a way that is over the top and unrestrains with
everything that you have. So look at these all love God with all your hearts. In English,
we tend to just associate the heart with our feelings. But there's more to that in the
scriptures. Our hearts also include our our thoughts as well as our desires. So all we think
about in our decisions as well. So our hearts are really our inner self. It's the center
of our motivations. So love God with all of that, your thoughts, your desires, your actions.
Love God with all your soul as well. So don't think of that in a way that's like kind of
separating out sort of soul and body. That's not what it's kind of talking about here.
It's it's not something that we have. It's so much as it's who we are. Right. So this is
when it's scripture talked about the soul, it's talking about our whole person. So you see
this in Psalm 103 verse one, bless the Lord, oh my soul. And it says the same thing in a
different way. And all that is within me bless his holy name. Right. So this is your whole person.
This is who you are the totality. Love God with all of that. And it says love God with all
your strength. I love this word. It literally means like your very muchness. So it's not
just a word for like might like power like weightlifting or something like that. It's your
very muchness. It's a word that amplifies and intensifies. I was at a concert the other day
and the sound went wrong during one of these songs and they literally had to stop the song right
in the middle of it. And the band was just a bit embarrassed and kind of dejected a little bit
as they're kind of fixing the sound system. But when they came back out, they played the
same song over again. Same song, same notes, but they threw themselves into it. I mean, they were
really going for it and really got the crowd going as well. So like the same song, but now this is
really like intensified. There was a lot more energy there. And this is kind of what you
have here with this word strength. All right. So love God and put your very muchness
into it as well. So this is how we love God with devotion to the highest degree.
So he is glorious and worthy of all that we are and all that we have at all times to the
nth degree. So in love, we are to enthusiastically devote ourselves completely to him from the heart.
It's like St. Augustine said in his confessions, he said this, he said, he loves these the prayer.
He loves the too little who loves anything together with the which he loves not for thy
sake. So all of life is to be lived as an expression of love to God.
So do we love him in that way? I don't. I certainly fall short. I'm sure if you're honest, you would say
you don't either. He is worthy of that, but we fall short. But the good news once again is that God
loves sinners. Jesus died for our failure to love him as we should in our lives and the place to go to
grow in your love for God. Right. So those who belong to him do love him and they want to grow in their
love for him. So the place to know God's love and to grow in his love is to see his love for you.
We love him, John says in 1 John 419. We love him because he first loved us. It is the love of God
that stirs our love for God and for others. So the love that we show him and others is like a
spark coming from the flame of his eternal love.
All right. So we've seen who we're to be paying attention to, to God. We've seen how we're to respond
by loving him. That comes from being attentive to his love for us. But then where is our love for God
then seen? In what context? We see that in verses 6 to 9. There's a kind of ripple effect that's
happening in the passage. If you kind of notice the flow of what's going on here, speaking
about God, most central to everything, speaking about us individually. But it also speaks about
the family and the community. It kind of makes its way outward, going out further. So the love of God
is present and our devotion to him is present in our hearts. Verse 6. He says,
these words I command you today shall be on your heart. All right. So there's a,
there's this call to continual personal attentiveness to God by listening to what he has told us about
himself in his word each day. So the things that we've been told about who God is and the kind of
relationship that we ought to have with him is something that we should have dwelling in our
hearts as we go throughout the day. And this is a commandment for all of us personally.
So I'm glad every single one of you are here in this corporate gathering of the church,
but know that this isn't just for us collectively or for somebody sitting beside you. This is for
you. So God is calling us each to look to him. And it's, it's good to speak about our relationship
with our families and we're about to see that in just a moment in what it says. But we must begin
even in our homes with our personal relationship with the Lord. In fact is you will love
your family best when you love God most. Right. So it's in putting him before all else that you're
enabled to to be who he calls you to be in life and in the home. So the greatest thing you can do for
your families, give yourself wholeheartedly to the Lord in every area of your life, including
your life with your family. As you do that, he helps you to grow as a parent. He's the one
who will supply everything that you need to love your family in the way that he calls you to love
them. And the same is true for every relationship that begins in our hearts. It moves out from our
hearts, yes, to our homes. So you see, verse seven, you shall teach them the commands of the Lord,
this revelation of God. Teach them diligently to your children. You shall talk of them when
you sit in your house and when you walk by the way and when you lie down and when you
rise. So our love for God is personal, but it is not private. It will come through in what we talk about
and what we talk about at home as well. So in a home where mom and dad really love the Lord,
that will be a home where they speak about the Lord. There's a story that I've heard
repeated all the time over the past few years and it's that people have, a lot of people
grow up in homes where kind of parents take them to church and there's talk about God there or singing
about God there, but Monday to Saturday it's, he's not present in terms of being talked about in the
home at all. So we might be singing to hymns alongside everybody else been in our homes. We never utter
a word about the Lord around our spouses or our children. We might say grace before eating a meal
together, but that is the extent of it. What we speak about or what we refrain from speaking about,
it reveals where our hearts are at. So Jesus said out of the abundance of the heart, the mouth speaks.
So here we see that parents are called to make the most of every opportunity to speak
to their children about the Lord. It talks about when we sit down. So maybe when you
sit down to have a meal together or when you're walking together or when you're on your commute
to school together in the car, make the most of that opportunity or when you put the kids to bed.
And here we see there's a kind of a mix of like structure and spontaneity. There's the kind of
regular habits of eating together or going to bed or that kind of thing. But then there's
just making the best of those smaller moments that pop up through the day. So there's these
intentional conversations going on. But the point is clear, parents have a responsibility to
disciple their children. That's what we were committing ourselves to earlier in the service.
And we're committing ourselves to support them in that. There's lots of way to do this in the
life of the church through your encouragement or teaching in Sunday school. There's a little
plug for more volunteers. They were always doing that. But we need us parents, we need you to
come alongside us. We need all the encouragement we can get. But you know what it says about
our physical earthly families, it's also true of our spiritual family as well. So what if us as
the family of God, the kind of what it says about our earthly families is true about all of us
together? Where we speak about the Lord. We spend time together first of all, and we speak about
the Lord in our conversations and encourage one another in that way. But it all goes back
to the heart. I love the Lord. And then the speech comes out. Then it moves from our hearts
to our homes to the wider community. And we'll kind of finish here. Notice what it says then,
verses eight and nine. You shall bind them as a sign on your hand, and they shall be as front
lets between your eyes. You shall write them on the doorposts of your house and on your gates.
So here you have these physical signs like I think something around your hand or this
this thing between your eyes on your forehead or putting something on your on your doorpost
or on your gates. These physical signs are then there as reminders of the Word of God.
So as the people of Israel went practice these things, they were reminded of the Word of God
where they went, but also what was visible to them is also visible to others. So you see,
have the Word of God in your hearts and when you're with your kids at home,
but even right out to the gates pointing out to the community, the Word of God should be
present there as well. Very public, what's on your your gates. And you might think this, well maybe
read this and you're thinking like deeply about, well maybe this was just to reinforce these
truths within Israel. And there's an element of that, you know, that be reminding one another's
community of the Word of God. But it extends beyond that. So Deuteronomy chapter four verses
six to eight, we see that there what what the people of Israel did was to be done
in the sight of the nations. So if they love the Lord with all that they had,
they put these things into practice, it will be a witness to the glory of God among the nations
around them. Right. So this this private devotion was being made public as they lived for the Lord
and proclaimed his name. The same is true for us as well. We love the Lord will speak about
him in the community to amongst those who perhaps do not know the Lord.
So everybody, everybody is an evangelist for the things that they love. Right. I was with a friend
yesterday and five minutes into the conversation, we were talking about mountain biking. I don't
mountain bike. I don't know hardly anything about mountain biking. I know how to ride a bike,
but but I know that he really enjoys it. And like we were straight into that conversation.
He was telling us about what he was what he had planned in terms of his next trip.
Maybe for you, it's your grandkids, like you're ready to talk to them about about them to anybody
who's willing to listen. Or maybe maybe it's like college sports or whatever it is for you.
Like you love it. You're ready to talk about it. You know, this is the key to
speaking about our faith. It's the key to evangelism really. It's not some big
program or being able to answer any question anybody might ever have before you say a word.
Here's the key. Love God with all that you have and then talk about what you love.
This is it. Like if God is the most essential in your thoughts and and permating everything
that you do, well, you will talk about what you love, no matter where you are. So the
apostles, you know, next chapter four, we're told no longer speak about Jesus. Like you
can't do that anymore. And they spoke up. They said, we can't help but speak about the things which we
have seen and heard. You know, we realized a number of years ago, and I still struggle with this,
that we tend to filter out like God talk depending on who we're around. Like if I'm
around a friend who's like not a believer, like an I know they're not or I won't talk about
God as much. Like if I'm near a Christian friend, I might say, Hi, yeah, yeah, we had a great
time at the at the prayer meeting last night. And with this other non Christian friend, I might say,
yeah, I had a had a great time with some friends last night. You hear the difference in those two
statements. And we were really challenged about just cutting that out and just removing
the filter like no matter who we are around to speak about the Lord freely as he enables us.
And I remember Julia had some great opportunities. I think about one particular
opportunity at a school back in England, she was at the school gate and making friends with
other moms that were there. And just saying that, you know, if something happened, well,
I'm praying for you and even offering to pray there just just speaking normally just as a
Christian amongst others who aren't necessarily that. And then there was this one particular
friend who had a family member pass away. And so they died and they spoke to Julia
about that. And so she was able to pray for them and speak comfort into her life. And then that led to
offering to read scripture with her. And then that became like a weekly Bible study where they're
then like speaking about the Lord together to that friend, then eventually coming to know the Lord
and worshiping alongside us in the life of the church. It wasn't some like grand program or
anything like that. It was just like, just speak freely, pray that the Lord opens up opportunities,
make the most of them when they arrive and praise God for what he has done.
But it all begins by loving God begins with him.
So what has our attention? Let's listen to him, be attentive to the Lord.
Know his love, grow in our love for him and speak about what we love. Let's pray.
Lord, I pray that you would help each of us to be attentive to you above all else.
Teach us to truly hear, to listen with a readiness to obey.
Lord, I pray that by your spirit that you would help us to really see and to know in the
depths of our being you are love and that you love us more than we can imagine.
Even to the point of Jesus being willing to lay down his life on the cross for us.
Lord, I pray that you would help us by faith to receive your love for us.
Lord, I pray that by your grace you would give us more of your love.
You'd help us to be a people who love you more and more and who love our neighbors
ourselves. In Jesus' name we pray. Amen.